physiquement, je n'ai jamais vraiment eu à
me pousser aussi fort et en termes d'endurance, tu es
comme oh mon dieu,
c'est comme une chose psychologique de
savoir que tu peux le faire de plus en plus et de plus en
plus daizy s'entraîne pendant un moment
où elle est sur les îles et  elle a
un moment pour elle-même et elle s'entraîne
avec le personnel, puis elle réalise
qu'est-ce que je perds mon temps à m'entraîner
avec le personnel J'ai
le sabre laser de Luke Skywalker dans ma sacoche, il
travaille juste sur les mouvements pour cette action
J'étais un professeur de planification elle  toute cette
routine en trois jours mais elle est
étonnamment tout en une
demi-heure elle apprend très
vite c'est la chose physique la plus difficile que j'ai
faite mais
la combinaison peut être très restrictive juste pour
emménager juste pour marcher tu fais le mouvement
et vous pensez que ça alors c'est l'heure du déjeuner mais
finem phasma se retrouve face à face, ce qui se
traduit par une grosse pipe une chose que je
ne voulais pas faire est de faire tout le combat
par moi-même
il y a une très bonne scène à tourner très fatigante là-bas
Ce
qui était cool, c'était d'apprendre différents
types de combats, c'était intense et amusant, un
entraînement très dur hier était super
et puis aujourd'hui nous avons commencé un Naja Slayer,
ils le surveilleront et il le
fera si bien à chaque fois que je veux dire
c'était  un peu comme oh mon dieu je peux faire
ça je pourrais faire ça
c'est juste rigoureux d'une manière géniale et
ces cascadeurs sont très disciplinés donc
vous ne pouvez pas avoir de
réponse d'actif absolument incroyable ils ont laissé
mes garçons et mes filles
vous